[Laughter]
I saw you on my a red-eye flight back
from Hawaii with your family oh and
um I think like the walk back to baggage
was about a mile and a half long yeah
and I thought to myself I actually
thought about you in this moment why
um because like when you see somebody
like oh that's Jim Jefferies and then
you see him and it's like oh he's a real
dad oh yeah you know I take care of him
and everything yeah oh he's a real
freaking bad but it's unfathomable
[Laughter]
doesn't make any sense honestly
you everyone who meets me they always go
can you
um can I do a video of you calling my
friend
my friend I used to go I don't really
want to do that I don't know your friend
now I've just given up to it I'm like
what's the name all right George mate oh
thanks brilliant right but people do
that when I'm with my kids
wow I woke up and they'll go they'll go
hey can you tell me my friend then he's
like Daddy's got some work
wow do they know what the word I mean
are they old enough to know about my
tank oh yeah one of them's 10 and one
okay one so yeah all right they're both
old enough to know words but one knows
more than the other yeah
um the 10 year old he's remarkable
really he's uh I've never heard I sort
of heard him swear once on a roller
coaster
no no the one where it's two roller
coasters and they sort of go into each
other and he said [__] as they went down
the hill ah and I said and like I know
he knew that he couldn't be disciplined
in that moment wow because I was
probably saying [__] as well right but
uh so run the house if he said it you
would no and I sort of swear in front of
him I thought he would swear but he just
doesn't do it yeah ah his mother's heard
him swear his mother said him swear a
couple of times but he's never sworn in
front of me except I think that's how it
goes if your parents are heavy with a
profanity at home the kids become the
opposite and if you never hear it like I
never heard it really it was always like
a bad thing yeah never allowed
Catholicism and then I couldn't wait to
say it well I'm a [__] up guy that's
why I was so afraid to have kids because
I know how I was as a kid like the
lighting things on fire shooting kittens
with BB guns beat your grandma I beat my
grandma with a [__] stick did she
beat you or no she was
to do this it's a Korean hello you know
what I mean what type of stick was it it
was one of those Willow sticks
like from the movie Willow
I don't know isn't a willow of a plant
of some sort or a tree yeah it's like a
bamboo shoot or something yeah yeah but
it's thinner and spikier oh it leaves
cool marks yeah does it make a noise
like a whip yeah good good but she
didn't because she was paralyzed from
the neck down she just smiled through it
and I was a kid so me and my brother
would just whip her with it until the
day came where my dad caught me
but she thought it was a bit of fun it
was her party trick yeah well she was
just like I think she was kind of like
not there could she talk no I would then
how do you know she was enjoying it the
face I can read faces Jim yeah
he kept on whipping at all
I think she liked the attention yeah oh
my grandkids are beating and I don't
feel it so I guess I'm okay with it but
is it really abuse if you're like four
or five years old oh no no I thought he
was doing this in his 20s
but I was afraid that if I had kids that
they were gonna come out like me but I
think you're right maybe I'll I'll like
give birth to like really like good kids
and when you want to do this
probably never right yeah how old are
you 51 yeah don't worry about it
don't do it don't do it Steve Martin did
it
Steve Martin's good Steve
oh he's got a thousand people to
probably take care of the game he's got
a really young wife or I guess he has to
be young to have the kids so yeah
um but no I like I said to my wife I
said I said when we get married I said
if you're not pregnant by the time I'm
45 I'm not doing it because after that
I'm not doing it oh wow and now I've had
the vasectomy also it's tied up I've I
well it's snipped or whatever does [__]
come out or no comes to see this is
funny because my father man I'm curious